chéri vous devez terminer cette émission
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup ri ce soir
mais on voulait bien sûr rendre un
hommage à maurane c'est avec une énorme
tristesse qu'on a appris aujourd'hui moi
je la pris dans la nuit à 4 heures du
matin j'ai appris que mourad nous avait
quittés elle a été trouvée morte à lundi
soir à son domicile alors qu'elle valait
tout juste d'annoncer son retour sur
scène
alors les raisons de sa mort sont encore
inconnues ce qui est incroyable c'est
que maurane était d'ailleurs remonter
sur scène le 3 mai il y a cinq jours et
elle avait l'air hyper en forme regarde
ce soir c'est une renaissance moi parce
que d'entre vous le savent peut-être je
remets les pieds sur une scène pour la
première fois depuis plus de deux ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
quand tu sais
je te
[Musique]
alors cette chanteuse qui l'accompagnait
a d'ailleurs posté une vidéo datant de
dimanche dernier on voit une morale
souriante et heureuse d'être sur scène
rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors la chanteuse c'est yves bareau
maurane ses 38 ans de carrière elle a
démarré sa carrière à l'âge de 17 ans
est ce que quelqu'un connaissait maurane
autour de la table ce que quelqu'un
vienne le lot pour lui si on avait l'air
pour la version ici c'est vrai et mourad
moi je les ai fait deux saisons de
nouvelle star avec elle et je me suis
régalé je vous dis la vérité c'était ma
préférée dans les membres du jury on
s'éclatait avant l'émission n'arrêtait
pas de rigoler ensemble je reprenais ses
chansons d'ailleurs elle en pouvait plus
l'arrêter pas de manière à nouna ferme
ta gueule et l été on rigolait tous les
deux et je jure que je vraiment changé
j'ai toujours eu voilà je l'avais
beaucoup beaucoup d'admiration pour elle
et c'est vrai que vous êtes en retour
parce qu'elle a écrit beaucoup sur
twitter sur vous elle vous avez
récemment c'est vrai alors faites vous a
préparé une petite compil du style
maurane à la nouvelle star et elle était
géniale au niveau du charisme se passe
pas grand chose parce que charisme de
boue des sources allemandes dihk
jeune c'est que vous avez un
vibromasseur dans la voix mais ça ne me
fait pas jouer ce personnage
la charisme de baignoires suisse
allemande pour moi je trouve ça très
élégant très élégant oui mais là la
proposition et pas assez pour durer
l'été
sincèrement l'était pas vraiment aller
dans l'important c'est plus la pleine
lune mais tu me fais chier c'est comme
c'est comme ça qu'on parle avec toi elle
est vraiment hyper drôle dans la
nouvelle star et on voulait vous
remonterez aussi la fois aux maurane
avait été très ému après avoir vu un
candidat se faire éliminer elle était à
fou dans l'émission non ça ne déchiffre
mais tu tires un plat sur les prime
je remettrai jamais en question ton
talent non
et j'espère temps pendant encore
longtemps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
et il y avait un moment que j'avais
chanté avec moi de vous rappeler que
j'avais chanté avec maurane way et c'est
vrai que j'avais eu beaucoup moins de
succès regardez que calme mais après
c'est toi sur mon coeur de kas 2
mais tu es tout pourquoi tout boss et
pour qui mais déjà tout pour qui te
pourquoi tu as ton pour un slalom
tu as tout pour eux seuls
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est vrai que lors du prime de 8 ans
elle avait twitté comme quoi elle elle
se pisser de rire est devant le prime
voilà en direct et c'est vrai que voilà
elle va beaucoup nous manquer moral et
je vous le dis c'était quelqu'un
d'exceptionnel elle avait un humour moi
je vraiment que je pleurais de rire avec
elle c'est celle qui je m'amuse et le
plus voilà je vous le dis dans la
nouvelle star